[Music]
High
I got
you Lord I hate that man that was Gavin
Newsome for those of you that are
listening on the audio podcast crashing
into to a kid in China while playing
basketball crushing the skull of a small
Chinese boy I'm Dave Rubin this is the
Ruben report it's November 7th 2023 I
wanted to play that clip up top because
uh not only do I obviously have no kind
words to say for Gavin Nome but uh on a
personal note just for 20 seconds I have
joined an over 30 men's basketball
league here in South Florida I had my
second game I I the league was filled
and they I was on like the emergency
list if someone gets hurt and over 30
basketball league somebody's going to
get hurt so the last place team that's
like 0 and five somebody gets hurt they
bring me in and I don't want to brag
everybody I scored one point last night
played the entire game scored one point
that's right I was one for two from the
line pretty good huh can I get an
Applause or
something one point I'm I think I'm the
oldest guy in the league at 47 which is
pretty sad but anyway life what are you
going to do okay we're going to shift a
little bit today obviously none of the
Middle East stuff is going anywhere and
and all of the horrors around that and
the reaction and everything else uh is
you know kind of going to be with us for
for quite some time right now uh but
there was a massive massive massive
story that broke last night that you
pretty much are not going to see on the
corporate press for good reason uh
Congressman Jim Jordan who almost was
speaker of the house a couple weeks ago
it didn't work out because he's kind of
too on the ball about the important
issues uh he released some information
that for sure like without question no
daylight uh the government has been
working with big Tech to censor private
citizens and you're not going to believe
this guys they censored Dave Rubin
that's right I'm on the list of people
that they now have evidence that the
government coordinated with private
companies to silence their speech uh on
tomorrow's show we are going to have
harit Dylan harit Dylan is one of the
premier First Amendment lawyers in the
entire
world uh we're going to have her on the
show to discuss what the recourse could
be you know if the government silences
you it's like do they have to pay you do
you get someone to does some mid-level
dingbat apologize to you a bureaucrat
show up to your house and say we're very
sorry we stepped on your first amendment
rights um I don't know we're going to
find out uh but I'm going to unpack
exactly what Jim Jordan released we're
going to connect that to what's going on
obviously on the Free Speech side of the
internet which really at this point is
is Twitter Rumble and locals that's
pretty much all we have left uh and then
we're going to also connect that uh to
this other story that broke yesterday
that again you are not going to hear
about in the corporate press and
hopefully we not get us kicked off
YouTube today uh but if we do get kicked
off of course we are on Rumble and
locals uh but Steven Crowder yesterday
uh released some of the manifesto it is
unclear how he got it and a lot of
people are trying to figure that out but
it is confirmed that it is legit the
manifesto of that shooter in Tennessee
that trans shooter a couple months ago
uh you all remember that story and now
we're seeing censorship related to that
Crowder just got a strike on his YouTube
channel is the is the channel taken down
altogether now or he cannot live stream
down but no strike so his channel has
been taken down apparently on YouTube
right now temporarily so we're going to
talk about it we'll see if uh we remain
here afterwards anyway we're going to do
all that and then I want to connect it I
want to jump dive back into presidential
Politics as well because there's a lot
of stuff happening uh with this debate
tomorrow Trump will be holding he's not
showing up to the baate which is a damn
the debate which is a damn shame because
if there was ever a time that we have to
have this battle of ideas like right in
front of us I would say it is now as we
seemingly are on the precipice of giving
away America all together I think it's a
really really weak move it does not
matter whether you love Trump or you
think he's up by 70 points or anything
else but there will be a debate here in
Miami tomorrow I will be there we're
doing a postgame show I'll have more on
that for you tomorrow Trump's doing a
counter rally here in Florida at the
same time so anyway it's a big show I'm
caffeinated and ready to roll let me
talk to you about moink box real quick
and then we'll get to it uh you guys
know that 60% of us pork production
comes from one company owned by the
Chinese and their Hogs are given
something called
ractopamine which is banned in 160
countries including China yet you find
it in your grocery aisle every day well
there's a better way I want to tell you
about moink you guys know it's moo plus
oink moink delivers grass-fed and grass
finished beef and lamb pastured pork and
chicken and sustainable wild caught
Alaskan salmon straight to your door
moink Farmers Farm like our grandparents
did and as a result moink meat tastes
like it should because the Family Farm
Does It Better the moink difference is a
difference you can taste and you can
feel good knowing you're helping Family
Farms stay financially independent as
well you choose the meat delivered in
every box like ribe eyes to chicken
breast to Pork CHS pork chops to salmon
fls and much more plus you can cancel
anytime Shark Tank coost Kevin o called
moinks bacon the best bacon he's ever
tasted and Phoenix right over here made
a filet minan last night that he was
raving about they guarantee you'll say
oink oink I'm just so happy I got moed
keep American farming going by signing
up at moink box.com Ruben right now
listeners of this show get free ground
beef for a year that's one of the best
ground beef you'll ever taste but for a
limited time Mo inkbox.com rubben white
box.com rubben and now back to me okay
so I want to dive into this before we
get into the specifics of what Jim
Jordan has exposed I want to connect
this a little bit to Twitter and Elon
Musk and Tucker Carlson who of course is
no longer with Fox and it still is
unclear why he is not with Fox but is
now doing his show on X uh X which is
formerly Twitter I guess we call it X
now uh anyway Tucker Carlson went on
Theo Von's podcast Theo Von's a comedian
he went on his podcast uh to talk about
sort of why he ended up on X and and
sort of the state of free speech and all
of the stuff take a look got on a
Twitter right and so I know that and
congratulations I think it's interesting
it's brave for people to get out of the
system a lot of people I was expelled
from the system but oh yeah yeah well
you know you got you got laid off from
everywhere was it cutbacks or why did
you cut backs
no I love I'm I'm going to use that
though there's downsizing just
downsizing yeah I'm being retrained I'm
learning to code
actually they closed the plant I totally
get I was on third shift and there just
the demand was in Decline um I am going
to use that though next time why were
you
fired but you got out and you moved to
uh I was thrown out thrown out and I and
Elon called me the day that I my show
was cancelled and um and I was grateful
that he did and he called you huh had
you spoken to him before yeah yeah yeah
okay yeah he I had and uh and I really
liked him and um I'm not a technology
person to put it mildly like at all yeah
very anology yep like almost on a crazy
sort of T kazinski way which is I'm not
defending it's so who handles tech for
you then kind of the tech people I don't
they they live in Bangalore I don't know
their names just kidding no we have
really super smart people the
bangalorean the
bangalorian no um actually our
Mandalorian most of our staff from Fox
came um and elon's I we don't work for
Elon I'm just I'm a Twitter user like
everybody else but his all he said was
um I'm going to keep the platform open
you know and people with differing views
whether agree with them or not are
welcome on the platform and and that's
that's the guarantee that I wanted and
needed and so I've been super grateful I
mean that's all I've ever wanted by the
way okay so I don't think uh Tucker said
anything there you that you kind of
haven't heard him say before right it's
still a little unclear as to why he got
fired did it have something to do with
the Dominion lawsuit and the 800 million
that fox had to pay because it happened
right after that maybe was he not going
to let that go did it have any to do
with his position on Ukraine or anything
else we just simply don't know at this
point I don't know that we'll ever know
maybe maybe Tucker knows and he's kind
of sitting on that or there's legal
reasons he's not talking about it uh but
the point is he's no longer with Fox the
number one cable news host in the
history of cable television was fired by
in essence the machine right and then he
goes to the place where Elon who then
bought Twitter for a cool 44 billion of
of a company that was purging money that
still is not profitable uh he bought it
so that he could enable people to say
what they will just like we're doing
right here with Rumble and again we'll
see if we're on YouTube by the end of uh
today so I want to show you a Tweet now
that uh Elon put up yesterday because
I'm going to connect this to the uh to
the Jim Jordan story so Jim Jordan
tweeted out bombshell report on the
censorship industrial complex and then
there's a long thread that I'm going to
get to in a moment and Elon wrote this
is a big deal because it is directly
directly connected to why Elon Musk
bought Twitter what the Twitter files
were all about and the subsequent uh
censorship of people like me and it's
and it's many more and it could be some
of you watching this right we don't know
the full list we only know some of the
sort of more public names anyway I'm
going to read you that whole thread and
connect that more widely to what's going
on in the country real quick let me talk
to you guys about the satellite phone
store uh guys fires hurricanes tornadoes
can happen almost anywhere and your cell
phone could go down as a result but not
a satellite phone satellite phones will
always work because you're carrying your
personal cell tower wherever or anywhere
you go on Earth everywhere or anywhere
you go on Earth anyone who has a
satellite phone in the affected areas of
Hawaii the Nevada desert say burning man
you've got a way to communicate with
friends family and Emergency Services
prepare for the unexpected the most
secure way to communicate is from
satellite phone to satellite phone you
can't be tracked and no one can listen
on your calls even the US military uses
satellite phones for secure
communication so here's my deal for you
visit
sat23 or call 866
320-1884 and use promo code Dave 50 to
wave the $50 activation fee the service
is only applicable to those in the
United States again just visit sat23 and
use promo code day 50 to wave the $50
activation fee or call 866 3201 1884 and
now back to me okay so why did I start
with a video of Tucker Carlson talking
about being free and being on X and
saying what he wants to say uh you might
remember Tucker Carlson what about five
years ago now in my humble Little Garage
Studio when he said Dave you've got
everything I want right because I I
happen to be one of the first guys to do
the independent thing right and now he's
he's traversing that landscape himself
well the only way that we can Traverse
that landscape the only way you guys can
watch this show or hear from alternative
voices forget about me specifically uh
is if there's infrastructure there are
places like Rumble and X Etc that allow
you to communicate with us that allow us
to create something that that build the
pipes so we can push it out to you so
that you can get it on your phone or
your laptop or anywhere else and what
the hope is is that the government is
not in between those connection points
us the Creator and you the consumer uh
making sure that you can see or not see
certain stuff unfortunately we have
found out that the government's doing
just that uh so now I've got quite a
quite a bit of a thread here from Jim
Jordan Congressman Jim Jordan bombshell
report on the censorship industrial
complex hundreds of secret reports show
that DHS goves and cisv which is the
cyber security and infrastructure
Security Agency the gec which is the
state department Stanford University and
others work together to censor Americans
before the 2020 election including true
information jokes and opinions the
federal government disinformation
experts at universities big Tech and
others work together through the
election Integrity partnership to
Monitor and censor American speech
according to one EIP member the EIP was
created at the request of cisa at the
head of the EIP the head of the EIP also
said that EIP was created after working
on some mod monitoring ideas with sisa
here's how it worked EIP stakeholders
including the federal government would
submit misinformation reports EIP would
analyze the report and find similar
content across platforms EIP would
submit the report to Big Tech often with
a recommendation on how to censor here's
where it's getting scary the Judiciary
GOP and at weaponization that's the
weaponization of government Department
obtain these non-public documents and
information from Stanford only after the
threat of contempt who was targeted
Americans of all political Stripes but
especially conservatives and then
there's a bunch of people here obviously
Donald Trump new Gingrich Mike Huckabee
shaan Hannity uh harit Dylan who's the
lawyer I'm gonna have on tomorrow
Charlie Kirk Jack poob okay you you see
a bunch of this Babylon B I mean there
are comedy site and it didn't stop there
here are some more accounts that were
targeted there's Newsmax oh Reuben
report how about that guy uh James o'
Keef uh what speech was targeted for
censorship true information jokes
political opinions the American people
deserve to know if they were targeted by
their own government and so-called
disinformation experts the committee is
making the data from these reports
publicly available here so now I want to
throw to a tweet of mine that I believe
is the first time I was ever suspended
from Twitter I've been subsequently
suspended a couple times although not
since Elon has taken over but this is
back in July it's July 29th of 2021 now
this is only a month after Joe Biden
gave a speech saying that vaccines work
and if you get the vaccines you will not
get nor transmit coid and I sense that
something was a little fishy so here is
what I wrote they want a federal vaccine
mandate for vaccines which are clearly
not working as promised just weeks ago
true people are getting and transmitting
coid despite the V true plus now they're
prepping us for booster shots true a San
society would take pause we do not live
in a sane Society uh I was suspended
from Twitter and if not had I not
created locals I would have had no way
really of getting my voice out there
after that I was able to post that on
locals and then a whole bunch of Twitter
people were able to link to that and
then eventually I was brought back on I
I'm not making this story about me and I
would also like to say it's like sort of
annoying and um it's like well I
don't want the government looking at me
like like it's sort of like ridiculous
and like not the the greatest thing ever
you know I guess it's like I see my name
in this it's funny when I saw the
original Twitter thre I started reading
it and I was like uh I'm going to be in
here aren't I anyway I mention all this
because now when you look back on on
something like that like saying vaccines
weren't working before it was cool to
say that saying that they were prepping
for us for booster shots when it was
obvious but you weren't allowed to say
it uh saying that mandates were coming
like it seems pretty clear and I'll I'll
try to contact Jim Jordan and find out a
little more information this that it's
very likely that that specific tweet
which I was right about all of those
things and all I was warning all I was
saying really was hey let's calm down
everybody let's pause for a moment
figure out what's going on here like
it's pretty clear that the government
worked with Twitter to silence me now
that's a direct assault on my free
speech First Amendment rights the
government cannot stop you from speaking
legally protected speech so the question
really is and I'll get to more of this
tomorrow uh the question really is well
what are what is your recourse if the
government silences you then what is
your recourse as a private citizen do
they owe you some cash as I said do you
get an apology does Joe Biden give you a
call like something unfortunately I
don't think you get anything actually
but we'll talk about that with harit
tomorrow uh we have a quick update
that's happening live on the fly right
now I mentioned that Crowder's YouTube
channel was down it apparently has come
back like within the last half hour so
again all all of this trickery the
shenanigans and everything else uh it
leads us to this odd place where we have
a a mainstream media that lies about
basically everything or they don't even
cover the stories that are important to
be covered that's a type of fake news if
they won't cover a certain thing uh or
they silence people etc etc so now I
want to connect this to the Nashville
Shooters Manifesto you remember this
story from a few months ago it turned
out that a trans person shot up this
school and then there was this this um
there was this very odd thing for a
couple days because it was known that
this person wrote a Manifesto and there
was this odd thing whether we could read
it who had it whether we were going to
find everything out and I just want to
broadly say before I get into the spe
specifics I'm I'm somewhat 5050 on
releasing information about manifestos
um I fully understand the reason to
release it right like you want to know
what the Insight you want you want to
glean some insight into what these
people were thinking so that you could
hopefully uh deprogram someone else who
might be going down that route right you
want to you want to know what their
influences were how corrupt their
ideology was were they on drugs all of
the were they abused like the Litany of
things that you might want to know about
someone who does like unimaginable evil
I think the Catch 22 to that although I
lean more on the former here The Catch
22 to that is is if every time someone
does one of these horrific acts one of
these school shootings whatever it might
be
if if our goal is to expose the
manifesto in some weird way you are
incentivizing them to do these things if
they want to be famous if they want to
be known if they want to be on the cover
of Rolling Stone remember that one like
you are incentivizing them to write
completely crazy things that may or may
not be true may or may not be the the
intentional motives of what they are
doing and you're saying to them we will
promote the hell out of it and I think
we just have to think about that a
little bit believe in free information
and and that we should be able to know
what's out there and everything else but
I think we have to be a little bit
careful putting pointing to something
that a that a crazy psychopath read and
and gleaning you know just too much
information into it anyway that being
said uh Steven Crowder has somehow got
this Manifesto and he released it so
here is a tweet from Crowder and we'll
see if we make it through YouTube today
uh breaking Nashville School Covenant
shooter Audrey hail's death day
Manifesto targeted crackers with white
privileges want to kill all you little
crackers these are quotes obviously from
the manifesto I hope I have a high death
count I'm ready I hope my victims aren't
ready to die uh Elon Musk responded to
this and he wrote this uh clearly
mentally ill but also clearly
brainwashed into being a mass murderer
by the system now I think it's worth uh
discussing that point for a second
because anyone who commits any of these
murders is mentally ill by definition
you guys remember that Uvalde shooting
in Texas the school where I think 18
kids and three teachers were shot Cold
Blood murder absolutely horrible that
was about six or eight months ago and we
played that clip of Joy Reed the next
day on her show saying that the shooter
was not mentally ill this was about the
guns and that is what a mentally ill
person would say the very definition of
taking a gun and shooting innocent
people children who you don't know all
of that that is by definition you are
mentally ill but that doesn't suit Joy
Reed and MSNBC and the Democrat party's
policy of wanting to step on your second
amendment rights right your ability to
own a firearm and protect yourself so
they don't want you to think about
mental health they don't want you to
think about the mindbending prescription
drugs that people are on or on this case
the fact that the shooter was trans and
there's probably hormones involved and
everything else so uh let's continue
because if it was not for rumble and X
locals Etc uh this story would not be
getting out there uh here is a tweet
from Steven Crowder uh Facebook is now
censoring the Nashville Manifesto uh and
then here we go YouTube yeah it took
down Crowder's video and called it
political violence they then took down
you Crowder's Channel which as I said a
moment ago they have subsequently
brought back just in the last little bit
but now I want to connect this you guys
know I like to connect these things in
in all sorts of levels right there's the
censorship level there's the the kind of
tech level the government level or the
cultural level all that stuff I want to
connect this now to the media level
because uh whether whether you think
these manifestos should be out or not or
any of the issues around that uh it is
now news and the question is how will
the media treat it as news now the media
obviously doesn't like Crowder Crowder
is competition to CNN the same way Joe
Rogan is competition to CNN or I am or D
Dan banino Etc so if if he is to expose
anything good not good in in and of
itself but if he is to expose anything
that is true well then they have to go
after Crowder uh so here's a tweet from
Crowder uh he said we called it this
morning expect hit pieces from leftwing
media saying we released the Nashville
Manifesto for clicks and clout I assure
you Crowder doesn't need clicks and
clout and here he has an email from a
New York Times quote unquote journalist
Emily Cochran uh and she says hi there
my name is Emily Cochran and I'm a
reporter with the New York Times I'm
working on a story on Mr Crowder's
publication of the Covenant writings and
just left a press conference where one
parent Brent Leatherwood was critical of
the decision to publish those photos he
described it as chasing clicks at one
point and said that the proceeds from
the video should go to the families of
the six victims and her school I watched
the video earlier this morning and will
incorporate some of that but wanted to
make sure Mr Crowder didn't have any
additional comment or response to the
push backat thank you Emily okay so
first off relative to how these Jour
quote unquote journalists operate
Emily's not terrible right there right
she's she's addressing a specific thing
she's saying I watched your video and I
want to give you a chance to comment
generally these people they tell you oh
you've got five minutes to respond to me
my hit the HIIT piece is about to come
out or they don't com you know they
don't ask you to comment at all um I
would say look I have
incredible I don't know how to describe
it any other way I have incredible
empathy and sympathy for the father of
one of these victims uh I I think that
you know that and he doesn't want is out
he doesn't want it rehashed but again I
think we kind of do need to know some of
the motivations here not withstanding
what I just said earlier about the way
they can manipulate that by writing
crazy things and everything else um we
also know that if if this wasn't a trans
person right if this had been a white
supremacist let's say or just a white
guy just a Christian white guy there's
no way this this Manifesto would have
been hit and they would have got oh my
God he watched Tucker Carlson and Steven
Crowder he voted for Donald Trump and
Joe Biden would have been speeches and
they would have been going after the
guns and all of that stuff um the idea
though that Crowder is doing this just
for clicks or influence like he's got
plenty of clicks he's got plenty of
influence the guy's making plenty of
money um so I just simply don't think
any of that uh holds water I would say
maybe Crowder it might just just for to
throw the thing uh just like offer a
little Penance or something to the evil
system not that it deserves it maybe you
just if you make any money on these
videos you donate it to some of the
victim's families or something like that
that that's for him uh to do uh but I
think the important thing is here is
that we have to expose the Liars in the
media who anytime anything true comes
out they try to take out the truth
tellers and of course that happens not
just with the media people but it also
happens with our political leadership so
now I want to show you you might
remember this this is the day after the
shooting okay so this is the day after
this trans person again hopped up on
what drugs it's still a little unclear
we now have some new information about
their intent and everything else the day
after they shoot these innocent kids at
this Nashville school what did
Jean God this woman what did Jean cringe
Pierre what did she do at the White
House well you may remember this and one
of the things that we saw during the
midterm elections is that people don't
want their freedoms to be taken they
want us to fight for their freedoms and
so it is shameful it is disturbing and
uh our hearts go out to uh th those the
trans Community as they are under attack
right
now our hearts go out to the trans
Community as they are under the Attack
under attack the bodies were still warm
and it wasn't of trans people they did
Kill the shooter by the way and then
remember there were um there were
protests at the Nashville state house
and uh they were include they said seven
people were killed the protesters and
they were including the trans shooter um
but you see what they do how everything
has to fit the narrative right so a
bunch of innocent people get shot by a
trans person and then Jean crin Pierre
oh we have to defend the trans Community
nobody's blaming all trans people but
either way either way our hearts should
go out to the families who were killed
by the
transperson right they do this with
everything and you guys know it you guys
absolutely know it if it it all has to
fit the narrative right a black guy
shoots a bunch of white people it's
because of systemic racism if a white
guy shoots a bunch of black people it's
because of white supremacy like you got
it by the way there was a uh I think a
68-year-old Jewish man uh was killed
yesterday at a Hamas well it was there
was an Israel protest like a pro-israel
protest and then some Hamas people were
there and one of the Hamas guys hit a
68-year-old man in the head with a
megaphone and killed him uh you are not
unfortunately going to see that on CNN
or MSNBC or anywhere else we probably
should have spent a little more time on
it today but again things that it
doesn't quite fit the narrative right
when the when the Jew gets killed by the
hamasa that's sort of supposed to happen
and you know it doesn't the power and
the oppression Olympics it doesn't all
fit the thing the way they want it to
fit the thing however we know that if a
Jew went out there and killed some
Palestinian protester a 68-year-old man
Obama would be giving a speech tonight
oh my God that guy could be my brother
and Joe Biden would be saying that
islamophobia is running running rampant
okay you get all that but let's connect
that to Joe Biden because just a day or
two after uh cringe Jean Pierre said
that about we have to help the trans
Community here even though it was a
trans person that killed a bunch of
non-trans people uh Joe Biden was asked
about the Nashville shooter and our
Christians being targeted and look at
his flip response to this thing you
believe that
I have no
idea they were what you say I probably
don't no I have no oh good good time to
joke and oh just because Josh Holly says
something you know like he's so muddled
it doesn't even matter it was a
Christian School by the way so every
single person should have been mourning
for those Christian children who were
shot not the trans Community right and
just every he's just he's just
absolutely terrible but uh being
absolutely terrible and blaming people
for things they haven't done uh is
exactly what this Administration has
done really since day one uh let's flash
back to Joe Biden's State of the Union
you're going to see some masks here so
it's during it's during the coid
pandemic remember that thing uh and
here's what he chose to scare the hell
out of people about what what's
happening in America there's some very
very scary people they're they're white
which is the worst of all colors and we
won't ignore what our intelligence
agency have determined to be the most
lethal terrorist threat to the Homeland
today white supremacy is Terrorism and
white supremacists will not have the
last word and this Venom and
violence cannot be the story of our time
enough of us have the guts and the
hearts to stand up to stand up against
the poison white supremacy as I did my
in aular address to single out as the
most dangerous terrorist threat to our
homeland is white supremacy according to
the United States intelligence Community
domestic terrorism from white
supremacist is the most lethal terrorist
threat in the Homeland white supremacy
is a poison it's a poison running
through it really
is
running through our body politic and
that's been allowed to fester and grow
right in front of our eyes no more I
mean no more that the ideology of white
supremacy has no place in
America none all right so you got it
he's very concerned about white
supremacy I I would make note that if
there is someone out there who wants
America to be a white supremacist Nation
where other people will not be treated
equally under the law or be under attack
or anything like that that would be a
problem I don't know of such people I
know that there are some bigots and you
know on Twitter people say mean things
to me and show send me pictures of
Hitler or if the Frog people are mean or
all of that but there is no mainstream
white supremacist movement it is just
not real now in some ways they are
starting to probably create it because a
bunch of white people good decent white
people are kind of feeling like they're
attacked all the time and when you're
feeling like you're attacked all the
time you might start stepping into some
uh bad ideas um but this is just
completely ridiculous if we were to even
look at the events of the last couple
weeks is it white supremacists calling
to kill all the Jews was it a white
supremacist who killed that elderly
Jewish gentleman in Los Angeles
yesterday uh or was it islamists or was
it radical leftists and marxists and
everything else like really just think
about it for a moment do you what what
seems like a bigger threat to America
that a bunch of white people who want
white water fountains and white buses
that they're trying to take over or that
there's this other really horrific
intersectional cacophony of ideas and
people that have come together the wers
and the gender queer nutbags and the
Hamas people and everything else who are
attacking the White House who are
calling for genocide and everything else
but if you say anything about them
you're called them islamophobe very very
bizarre but now I want to connect this
perhaps to a way out because I actually
do think that there is a way out because
we have a presidential election coming
and if we stop with the Liars if we find
some people who will tell us the truth
who will govern the way uh we were set
up to be governed maybe we can get out
of this one of the interesting thing
that's happening right now is that even
though we're about two months away from
the first uh Primary in Iowa uh Ronda
santis yesterday got the endorsement of
Iowa governor
Kim Reynolds I've had Kim Reynolds on
the show I think she's excellent I think
she would really make a great VP uh
everyone if you were to Listen to
Conventional wisdom and mainstream media
Donald Trump's up by 50 points and blah
blah blah but as you know the santis is
going to all 99 counties I think he's
been to about 90 of them already in Iowa
getting big crowds everywhere he now has
the endorsement of the governor I think
something on the ground is happening a
little bit differently but putting aside
Iowa for a moment getting back to just
the idea portion of this what if we
actually had politicians who told us the
truth and who defended our rights and
got out of the way and then you had a
little skin in the game to see if you
could figure out how to live your life
you think America might work I think it
might here's Ronda Sanz look I would say
this to young kids um it was the
Democrats that were isolating you in
your dorm rooms during coid it was uh
Republicans like me in Florida who were
liberating you from those coid
restrictions we weren't trying to Force
coid shots on you when you didn't need
it and you were at low risk for coid uh
the uh the inaccessibility of the
American dream for people in their 20s
that's because of liberal policies that
have driven up the cost of energy
interest rates all these other things
you know we're the response to those
policies you know we're going to give
people a chance to get ahead again uh in
this life and as hard as it is for uh
people you know that that have kids
already and elderly people on fixed
income you know if you're 23 and you
have student loans and you're trying to
get ahead I mean man uh this is not a
good time uh to be able to launch
yourself uh going forward so we need to
do something about that we got to
restore the American dream we got to
show young people that hard work will
pay off again in this country and if you
work hard get the most of your god-given
ability you will get ahead I want to ask
for all of your support uh in January
when we have the New Hampshire primary
uh we need to nominate somebody um who's
going to be able to uh unite this party
uh win the election and ultimately you
know unite this country look let's put
the uniting the country aside for a
second and everything else just the idea
that a politician would get up there and
say yeah it could be tough for you 23
year olds but we have to basically what
he saying is create the conditions so
that you can get into the world and
maybe get ahead and that maybe hard work
would matter right like that's the truth
and that's what this country is based on
and I still believe maybe I'm just a
dreamer but I still believe that if you
tell the truth and you do the right
thing and you work hard you can get
ahead and that is what we're on the
precipice of giving away so I want to
contrast that to some lying and I know
people are going to get pissed at me
right now but over the weekend there was
a giant Republican event here in Florida
where they had all the candidates they
had all the Florida Republicans and
everything else both Ronda santis and
Donald Trump spoke uh and Donald Trump
got some booze from the Florida
Republicans because he started talking
about coid what states did well under
coid while he was in Florida the state
that he lives in and all his kids live
in and all his grandkids live in and
everything else and he forgot to mention
a certain State while he was talking
about uh what states did things right we
did a great job in Co we never got the
credit for the job we did we let
Republican governors keep their states
open many of them did Henry McMaster
South Carolina did a great
job South Dakota did a great job
Tennessee did a great job a lot of them
they kept them open
[Applause]
[Music]
no he knows goddamn well what he's doing
and it's not cool and it's not right Don
Donnie if you're up by 50 points if
you're so confident and you think the
sanctimonious has no chance then why not
say the truth why not say the truth
actually he did do a good job it's why
I'm here it's why my family moved down
here during all of this and and I think
where I'm at with all of this and I
haven't done the presidential racehorse
politics in a couple weeks in light of
what's going on in the world but having
just come back from the arc conference
and and listen to so many great speeches
about how we can reset the world and get
things right again and the overarching
theme that Jordan Peterson constantly
talks about that I try to uh you know
put into this show is I don't think we
can beat Lies by lying I just don't
think we can I I I don't think it will
work it might get you some temporary
wins but it will not get us the ultimate
win so why couldn't he just go up there
and say boy we did do some right things
and it was the Republicans and by the
way even even if he won't call him the
the santis even the sanctimonious did a
good job but but then his own audience
turned on him there and I think it's
important to note and you have to decide
for yourself and you just may you may
not disagree with me right and this has
nothing to do with any of the the trials
and tribulations of Donald Trump and all
the unfair prosecutions and everything
else which I think we're all probably on
the same side of but if you think that
the lies will get us out of this and I
mean this more in an existential way
right I mean this
philosophically more than like
granularly I don't think the lies will
get us out of it what out of this what I
think is that the truth and exposing the
lies will get us out of this uh so now I
want to show you an interview that Dan
santis did uh is this is the uh scarbo
one or it's the other pbd uh sorry this
is the pbd podcast Patrick B David
podcast so this is last week here in
Florida uh Patrick B David who's a Budd
of mine he had long wanted to Sant this
on I was able to help facilitate it
which I was very happy to do uh and they
got into and Patrick by the way who also
just like me and many of you moved to
Florida during coid because of what Des
santis did Even though Trump at the end
of Trump's president he was presidency
was still pushing D santis to lock down
and he would not uh Patrick brought up
coid and policy and things of that
nature with the governor take a look was
a very tough season where you know even
Obama Biden none of these guys had
prepared for a pandemic the only one
that knew a pandemic was coming was a
guy named Bill Gates everybody else is
like well yeah but here's the thing you
you don't know that's true and I think
there was a lot of uncertainty in March
of 2020 the question is what about
November of 2020 December January of
2020 what should he have done what
should he have done he should have fired
fouchy he should have held these people
accountable for being wrong for lying to
the public on all these different issues
the corrupt medical swamp in DC was a
total disaster I'll tell you what they
also shouldn't have done January of 2021
last few weeks in office there sending
me missives uh from the White House task
force saying impose a mask mandate close
restaurants do and I'm just thinking of
myself and the media here would use it
as fodder they would say DeSantis is not
following the Trump White House task
force and I wasn't that's a true but
they you the media use that as a wedge
so I I think that the whole fouchy and
here's the I think the issue for for the
election going forward is I'm the only
one running that is talking about
bringing accountability for what
happened to this country during
it's one thing to make a judgment call
that's wrong but it's another thing to
ignore evidence it's another thing to
lie when you tell people like CDC did
that if you take an mnra shot you will
not get coid and you still stand by that
when it's obvious that people are
getting it when you're having the FDA
approve an MRA shot for six-month-old
babies where there's no evidence that
that's benefiting them this is a swamp
this needs to be cleared out you know we
can endlessly rehash and everything else
and sometimes watching some of the old
videos of it it's like ah we've been
through this already but what he's
really right about there is that he will
bring a reckoning do you realize guys
that we will go through this again and
again and again whether it's coid or
coid 7 or a zombie apocalypse or World
War III or whatever else they want to
lie to us about or anything until we
actually have a Reckoning with these
people how are these these places like
the NIH and CDC how have they not been
annihilated and destroyed but imagine if
say Ronda Santos was president and
imagine if say he was like hey uh RFK I
know we're uh not totally in line on
everything you're you're a former Dem
like a pretty recent Dem but could I
task you with going to the agencies it's
been your lifelong career uh take you
know as a lawyer going after big
agencies can I task you with taking out
the CDC and the
NIH you think he might do it RFK who
wrote a book about bouchi and the evil
corruption at these agencies like do you
think think they might do it do you
think Trump can do it like do you think
he has the right people around him that
can do it and do you think it's
important to do I I do think it's
important to do but it's obviously it's
not just coid we also have to have some
real talk when it comes to everything
border economics etc etc and now here's
a wild one from the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC Ronda santz
went on there talked to Chuck Scarboro
who has taken every side of every issue
it's how it's how he survives on
television because he says everything
and means nothing uh and de santis
actually kind of got Scarboro to make
some sense and made a real point about
Republican hypocrisy when it comes to
spending do you think the uh House
Republicans and all Republicans uh in
Washington was we'll just say generally
Washington Republicans have been
hypocritical on the issue of balancing
budgets paying down the debt under
Donald Trump as I'm sure you know of
course Joe of course the
debt the debt exploded yeah the last
time Republicans did anything about it
was when you were in Congress that was
the last time Republicans actually
walked the walk when they had the
Republican Revolution why is that
Governor because you know when I'll just
say when we were there we raised we
raised hell but we balanced the budget
four years in a row George Bush gets in
the deficit
explodes uh Obama gets in Republicans
actually put in some restraints on
spending Trump gets in worse than ever 8
billion over four years worse why is it
that Washington Republicans only care
about the deficit when there's a
democrat in the White
House well I think if you look at the
Unified Government over W bush and under
Trump Republican Unified Government they
threw out all the fiscal uh constraints
that was not something people cared
about uh if you talked about it at that
time it was like they didn't want to
hear it the minute Republicans get out
of power then all of a sudden they be
beat their chest they become real fiscal
Hawks right so the end point there thank
you Joe for letting your guest speak for
a moment the end point there that
Republicans always scream about this
stuff cut the deficits Rin back spending
blah blah blah blah blah when they have
majorities when they have the house and
the presidency they don't do much in
Florida we do right in Florida right
here we still somehow we have a chief
executive the governor de santis who's a
republican we have super majority in the
house we still cut back spending we're
still funding the right things uh we're
giving bonuses to police officers who
want to come from other states to do
good work here you guys get it all the
good stuff about Florida that I could do
endlessly uh but the point is that maybe
maybe we could have someone in the White
House who would bring that Reckoning on
coid maybe we could have someone in the
White House who could Usher in a time of
I don't know Republicans acting like
conservatives and cutting back spending
and having clean bills and all of those
things maybe we could have that
or and perhaps we're going to choose
this one and we'll get exactly what we
deserve we can have an endless circus we
can have an endless circus of name
calling and belittling and everything
else here's Donald Trump yesterday on
true social if and when Kim Reynolds of
Iowa endorses Ronda santimon
who is absolutely dying in the polls
both in Iowa and Nationwide it will be
the end of her political career in that
Mago would never support her again just
as Maga will never support the sanc
demonius again two extremely disloyal
people together getting together is
however a beautiful thing to watch they
can now remain loyal to each other
because nobody else wants them three
exclamation
points so we can decide like guys you
know I don't have Trump derangement
syndrome or any of those things if he is
the nominee I will vote for him but if
you want that if you want more of
that then you'll get more than that more
of that and I suspect we will not get
out of any of these problems or maybe we
can and I think Trump knows that the
santis is doing far better in Iowa and
probably in New Hampshire than than the
media will allow you to believe right
that's why he's going after him all the
time uh by the way yes as I mentioned
earlier Kim Reynolds she did endorse
Donald Trump here they or sorry she did
endorse Ronda santis here they are
together yesterday got a lot of great
candidates that are running for office I
I consider them friends I've had the
opportunity to campaign with them I
appreciate all of them stepping forward
and putting their lives and their
livelihoods on on the line to have the
opportunity to represent this country
but I have to take a look at everybody
as somebody who's a leader you should
want people people who are delivering
big victories for their constituents
standing up for conservative values
which Kim has done and it's almost like
w with Donald Trump if you don't kiss
the ring you could be the best Governor
ever and he'll trash you you could be a
terrible corrupt politician but if you
kiss his ring then all of a sudden he'll
praise you yeah I mean that's just true
and we all know it to be true even you
watching this right now if you're hugely
in the Maga camp and you're pissed at me
for doing this segment or these last few
minutes you know that part is true right
it's it's illustrated by the fact that
Donald Trump over the weekend was
talking about all the great Republican
Governors on coid in Florida and forgot
to mention the Florida guy and got booed
in Florida right this is the same guy
Donald Trump who now says uh Andrew
Cuomo did a good job during coid Andrew
Cuomo should spend the rest of his life
in jail for what he did by sending all
those old people back into the into the
homes and all of those things where so
many people died
okay all of that being
said you don't have to believe me you
don't have to believe Ronda santis you
don't have to believe Kim Reynolds or
anything else you have to make a
decision for yourself I think that is
the important thing here you have to
take the information what I try to do is
just give you guys some information I
tell you what I think you have to take
some of that information and then figure
out what you think right you don't want
to be you can turn on many other shows
where guys are just going to yell over
the top and try to convince you of every
other thing that's not the way to do it
I think maybe it's why this thing's
working over here and it's also why
people are paying attention to Tucker
Carlson so one more from that interview
the only thing that enrages me is when
you hear people say you know you must
believe me I have no obligation to
believe anybody you have an obligation
if you want me to believe you to prove
what you're saying right and I have a
right to ask simple fair questions how
do you know that how can I trust that
how and if and if you don't give me
those answers then I just don't believe
you and I don't have to believe you and
if your recourse is you're a bad person
for not believing me Fu you that's my
response
you not end the show by saying that but
I will end the show by saying think for
yourself think for yourself make some of
these decisions for yourself think about
like how do we get out of this like is
the truth that we can make America great
again right now or is the truth that we
better freaking save America First make
America was great again was nice now I
think we're at the stage of like we got
to save this freaking thing or we are
going to you know just Veer off that
cliff into hell I would prefer not to do
that that is our show for today I hope
you've enjoyed it uh as you guys know we
launched our second show as of yesterday
1 pm Monday through Thursdays it's our
call-in show where we take calls from
you guys for the uh few people asked uh
for now we're only taking calls from
locals members that's our very easy it's
a very simple way for us to just screen
call so we don't get all the like true
internet Psychopaths and everything else
I am fairly certain we'll get less
internet Psychopaths because we're also
showing your face on video and generally
psychopaths are quiet and in a basement
and Anonymous and everything else uh but
if you want to submit some questions you
can do that right now at Ruben report.
locals.com if you want to watch the 1 pm
show it'll be right here live streamed
at rumble.com rubben report my full
interview with Douglas Murray shot on
location at ARC we shot about 20
interviews they're all going to be
coming out this week the Douglas Murray
one is the first one and he he is just
in rare Douglas Murray like clear
concise form uh that's up across
platforms right now and uh we leave you
we haven't played a clip of the view in
a while so it's just some crazy woman
screaming on The View goodbye when when
I got to SNL there was so many things
that I learned about that I didn't even
know like seriously the electorial
college I didn't know about that I was
just don't I know you're gonna be mad
when I say this I did think it was a
college College I
thought you built the Electoral col I
thought that that you know the the
people got to go there before they
become a politician oh I wish that were
the case listen the people voting for
Trump should go to college exactly
exactly so that's that's things like
that to learn
[Music]
all